ukrainian refugees have fled often
without knowing where their next meal
will come from
inside the country's besieged cities
food is running out a tragic irony in a
part of the world long known as the
bread basket of europe ukraine and
russia are huge producers and exporters
of grains and oil seeds but many
ukrainian farmers have left the fields
to fight and black sea ports are closed
right now knowing how much black sea
actually matters in the scale of the
international grain export
it's it's going to be very very and very
bad the war has strangled supply with
the price of wheat and sunflower seeds
breaking records about 80 percent of
sunflower oil
comes from these two countries
so
the the impact of this crisis is
worldwide this is a disaster for
struggling countries close to ukraine
lebanon where the economy is already in
tatters gets most of its wheat from
there war-torn yemen where hunger is
already a huge problem relies heavily on
affordable grain imports the ripple
effects could soon be felt even more
strongly according to this ukrainian
trade expert it's not just some local
ukrainian russian war and if you don't
have another refugee crisis from those
areas which which will be under fed
this is something that the world needs
to do we need the way of ending this the
world food programme says the war
compounds the effect of covet 19 climate
change and other conflicts it says 44
million people are already on the edge
of famine and that could rise further
unless it gets more funds better still
would be an end to this and other wars
redmond shannon global news london